greetings everyone I'm alive and welcome
to my channel today we are doing another
Q&A at the eating 130 thousand
subscribers thank you guys so much
sorry this video is kind of all a
technical earthly 132 now I've just been
traveling so much it's been hard to find
the time to make videos that I couldn't
do was like vlog style on the go but I'm
here now doing right now to school on
Instagram asked what's the first game
you ever played I think it was a game
called moto racer which was a PC racing
game but I'm actually not sure I started
gaming at a very very very young age
and so I effectively don't remember my
parents don't even show what it is but
yeah we think moto erisa Jake in zero
five one three on Instagram us what's
your favorite burrito or taco not a huge
fan of tacos no burrito is very good
especially now that I'm living in
California I didn't realize how good
burritos actually are because Australian
Mexican food is not very good big well
underscore de navarra on school 15 asks
what's something that a lot of people
like that you just can't get into I only
realize this recently but walking
simulators video games that don't have
combat generally are tough for me to get
into and there are totally exceptions to
that I don't know if it aside counts as
one of those games but I love inside but
games like what remains of Edith Finch
games like Johnny like night in the
woods stuff like that I just um I just
can't get into them that's the answer
comic don't Instagram oz do you have a
New Year's resolution of gold this year
if so how are you sticking to it my new
year's resolution this year which I
spoke about in my 2017 goodbye video one
pot stock podcast did that it's going
great getting new microphones this week
very excited about that the other one
was like spend less time walking one
time having fun in San Francisco and I
failed at that miserably I probably
walked more this year than any other
year so far not been doing a great job
that pot reclose a 1 0 2 0 oz weirdest
fan interaction um there are plenty of
weird things that have happened on the
internet but that's like that doesn't
count that's the intent in person if you
ask me to lick something
I'm probably going to find that a little
bit weird shans more on us
congratulations ellonija videos really
awesome you deserve it
thank you question do you play Emily
geez if so what is your favorite I have
I'm not currently playing an MMO my
favorites are Neverwinter which I
understand is a weird pick and Gilmore's
to misty 78 on Instagram
you made a video about Game Stop so
what's the worst thing about working in
games media definitely work-life balance
I don't know if that's just me
specifically but walking constantly lots
of weekends lots of time spent on planes
always having too much to do and never
really getting time to myself and also
you know living in San Francisco meeting
that I can't spent a ton of money even
what I do have done to myself so I feel
guilty if I like go out to eat or
anything so yeah it's that for sure Iram
is 0:07 asks what's the first thing you
pay attention to when you see a guy
don't tell me its personality
um how they hold themselves and what
they're wearing style I suppose or just
the the most fitting one that comes to
my mind is aura but I don't believe in
literal auras so just like the sense
that you get from someone doth
incredible boy ooo doth incredibly
rather very smart
on Instagram asks would you rather drink
lemonade while swinging on a swing set
or drink chocolate milk while watching
Saturday morning cartoons you know I
only realised like maybe two weeks ago
that I have never had actual lemonade
before not that I can remember at least
maybe I did at some point in my
childhood but I'm pretty much positive
I've never had lemonade because in
Australia lemonade is just right so I
don't think I've even [ __ ] tried it
but my choice would be the swinging on
the swing set I think I think a lot of
my happiness is dictated by the Sun if
I'm outside I'm in the Sun I feel very
very happy I don't watch a lot of TV I
don't really watch movies aside from
video games which is like totally an
exception to that being outdoors
drinking lemonade if I like it sounds
nice style since and which part of your
job do you enjoy more performing on
camera producing videos of researching
such writing 100% writing that is my
favorite thing to do and I think
probably always will be and always has
been that includes like helping other
people with their writing I really
really like to
big underscore are so on in three
mosques would you want to be a guest on
more of the receipt podcast in the
future if you could
I've already been always open and on
dude soup and totally be down to more of
them to do more of them that's what I
meant to say just then but zing is Shane
zero said if you could work for any game
studio of who and why would for sure be
Rev and a because of where they located
like I would love to live in the UK
closer to the EU but also just because I
love so many rare games I love this
style in their personality and I like
everyone that I have met who watched
this so yeah for sure red apathetic dot
Antonia will you ever do gaming on your
channel there are tons of Let's Plays on
my channel I get this question so much I
think I answered it in the lost Q&A I'm
not allowed to do Let's Plays those
streams while working in IGN but they're
all old Let's Plays on my channel that
you can still go and watch the last one
I posted was the day before I started
working in the IGN office so it's still
there I didn't fall until Boehm let's
play series ok moving over to Facebook
travel Whaley us what's your favorite
and least favorite part of hosting daily
fixed favor pod probably the people I
work with getting to like just hang out
with the producers in the morning you
know it's the first thing that we do dan
and Bob are both really great people and
we have a lot of fun making the show and
like just making jokes in the morning
it's it's a lot of fun in terms of that
least ever pod I mean the comments and
generally pretty horrendous they're
definitely getting better now that I'm
actually paying attention to them in
moderating them and all that stuff which
I don't think we did before I started
doing it but yeah that's still pretty
bad Ian gotta Aussie would be a perfect
video game romance from any games genre
and yeah I have a youtube video about
this exact thing where I ranked the top
five dudes in video games I don't know
if he was my number one but right now
because I'm playing through it again I'm
gonna say Geralt from The Witcher he was
definitely in that video I just don't
remember like which where I ranked him
in it I can link it below if you guys
haven't want to see that and that is it
everyone thank you all so much for
asking questions and all that stuff and
a huge thanks to everyone whose names
are on screen right now for supporting
me on patreon I'm really keeping at my
channel going when the ad pocalypse hit
and I thought that I had to stop doing
it I love you all so much I hope you
enjoyed this Q&A
now we'll see you guys later this week
bye